[Musik]
sind sie glücklich
ja ja ja ich bin nicht wirklich
glücklich ja was macht sie dann zu
glücklich ja ich weiss nicht direkt aus
dem geschäftsleben schönefuß hübsche
frau die kinder am alles ist gut
besser ausgelegt wird ich sage
fantastisch was wenn man dort angekommen
ist wo es nun noch fantastisch ist darum
geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
später zeige ich ihnen wo george bush
wohnt aber das können sie nicht filmen
die dürfen nicht mal die kamera sehen
der secret service ist da die verhaften
wir befinden uns in dallas im
bundesstaat texas also im süden der usa
markt über 10 von schweizer auswanderern
hat hier ein vermögen gemacht indem er
frauen träume verkauft wobei träume
brüste bedeuten
täuber ist einer der bekanntesten
schönheitschirurgen der region seine
praxis an der lemon avenue ist gut
besucht
seine frau carey spritzt frauen falten
weg und macht die lippen voller außerdem
assistiert ihrem mann bei seinen
operationen
ich denke frauen fühlen sich dank
schönheitschirurgen besser ich wollte
nur mal sehen was er macht ich gebe ein
interview wieso kommen frauen
ich denke frauen kommen hierher weil sie
sich der schönheitschirurgie besser
fühlen sie bekomme ich mir
selbstvertrauen und sind zufriedener mit
ihrem leben
sein erfolg habe auch mit dem richtigen
standort zu tun sagt täuber in den usa
gebe es drei hotspots für
schönheitschirurgie los angeles new york
und eben dallas wann haben sie
abgenommen
ich habe 2002 ungefähr 150 pfund
verloren und dieses jahr noch einmal 80
pfund
wie haben sie das gemacht gesund essen
täglich sport treiben
jane dough ist fast vier stunden
gefahren und teuber zu sehen nach drei
kindern und einem massiven
gewichtsverlust wolle sie sich mit hilfe
von silikon endlich wieder attraktiv
fühlen sagt die enddreißigerin seine
arbeit drehe sich nur vordergründig um
den traum von schönheit sagt täuber
tatsächlich geht es um erfolg der
schönheit machen erfolgreich findet sie
dann dass sie so schön sind
nein nein ich bin vielleicht ist er ja
ja nur und trotzdem erfolgreich ja ja es
ist komisch ja vielleicht bin ich nur
ein lucky sind einfach glücklich dass
ich nicht noch mal ja
seine schöne frau carey lowell bei der
arbeit kennen
er engagierte sie als op
krankenschwester und irgendwann wurde
mir heraus haben sich sofort gedacht das
könnte ein mann sein für mich ich habe
überhaupt nicht gedacht dass das ein
mann wäre für mich ich habe mich noch
nie mit einem chef eingelassen
das war eine rein professionelle
beziehung
ich fühlte mich nicht von ihm angezogen
ja das kam über nacht ein schalter wurde
umgelegt ver in einer beziehung
dann trennte er sich von seiner frau und
ich war gerade single also dachte ich
vielleicht ist da etwas davor hatte ich
nie daran gedacht mich auf ihn
einzulassen
[Musik]
die drei personen in der besten gegend
von dallas
das ist eine der berühmtesten straßen in
der list ray lane
die straight line befindet sich in einer
gegend namens preston hollow so etwas
wie die goldküste in zürich
[Musik]
machen sie hier niemanden sauer die er
schützen sie wäre es hierher geschafft
hat hat offenbar etwas richtig gemacht
im leben die frage ist nur was
wahrscheinlich haben die meisten hier
einfach die richtigen hände
hier sind viele es davon ab ob man aus
einer guten familie stand natürlich gibt
es hier auch gute geschäftsleute aber
viele wurden durch öl und gasreiche sie
nennt das den klub der glücklichen
spermien
die wurden in den club der glückliche
spermien geboren darüber hatte dieses
glück nicht er hat sich alles selber
erarbeitet als er zwei jahre alt war
wanderte und seine eltern in die usa aus
und er schaffte den sprung vom
mittelstand in die oberschicht
[Musik]
mit ende 40 arbeitet heute nur noch vier
tage pro woche um macht jedes jahr zwölf
wochen ferien
trotzdem wird er in reicher er gilt
ungern aus am liebsten verbringt er
seine freizeit zu hause und kocht für
seine frau und seine dreijährige tochter
ich muss all die hilfskoch arbeiten
machen
die wichtigen dinge machen kann muss man
solche arbeiten erledigen für markdorf
ist es die zweite ehe für seine frau
carey bereits die dritte diesmal passe
alles finden beide
sie seien angekommen beieinander und
hier in dieser villa ich habe mal ein
gedicht geschrieben dass meine oma
aufbewahrte der weisen der vierten
klasse ich schrieb ich bin lustig aber
zielstrebig ich war wohl schon immer so
ich war immer lustig und zielstrebig ich
hatte keine besonderen ziele im leben
ich wollte nur eine krankenschwester
sein oder berühmt werden
aber ich wollte es immer zu etwas
bringen in was für frauen verlieben sie
sich
ich würde sagen in frauen mit großen
brüsten
das finden die später nicht lustig
nein ich fühle mich zu chloren und
interessanten menschen hingezogen zu
mentioned ambitionen ich muss ein mann
intelligent sein gesicht und ich will
mich nicht langweilen er muss mich zum
lachen bringen und unterhaltsam sein mag
ist sehr unterhaltsam
könnten sie mit einem orden mann
zusammen sein wenn der unterhaltsam wäre
ich war auch schon mit armen männer zu
sein
beim zur heirat war ich auch an
nein aber ein reicher mann kann genauso
unterhaltsam sein wie ein armer geld ist
mir egal mir ist die person wichtig
das sind auch stereotype dass sie hübsch
ist und ich reich bin und dass wir
deshalb zusammen ich war vorher auch
nicht an unsere heirat war sie noch
nicht so wie du bist so gemein
ein bisschen huhn und ein paar bohnen
müssen reichen
bei ihnen kämen keine schlechten
kalorien auf den tisch erklären mir die
deutschen das heißt möglichst wenig
kohlenhydrate bloß keinen zucker dafür
fidschi mineralwasser
übrigens in texas für den nächsten
morgen hat carrey die braune
yogalehrerin bestellt mark hat
versprochen mit zu machen obwohl er
handy gebiert ist er habe probleme im
hüftbereich sagt er mir vielleicht habe
er sich zu viel zugemutet
also im hüftbereich zwinker zwinker wie
auch immer er zieht sich schon bald
zurück
[Musik]
weiter für den erfolg für einen erfolg
für den mann laut reuters vor allem auch
gut aussehen muss jedenfalls als frau
ist schwer marc zu motivieren mit ihnen
mitzuhalten wenn nicht kannst du das ist
seine motivation
er hat 70 pfund verloren
35 kilo wenn er wieder zunehmen
ich liebe ihn so oder so würde mich
immer noch lieben sie würde mehr von mir
ein bisschen billiger geht ja ich würde
mir von ihm ein bisschen viel erleben
[Musik]
nun zum blutigen teil der
schönheitsindustrie überführt rund 400
operationen pro jahr durch drei viertel
davon sind brustvergrößerungen heute
stehen sechs auf dem programm
eine davon ist jane dough die sich nach
drei kindern und über 100 kilo
gewichtsverlust wieder attraktiv fühlen
möchte darüber ist ein schneller weiter
für eine normale brustvergrößerung
brauchte nur gut 20 minuten bei jane
dough dauert das sind es fast eine
stunde bis ihre neuen brüste fertig sind
7000 dollar kosten das früheste im
durchschnitt oder wie er sie nennt die
turboboost mit denen inzwischen einige
tausend amerikanerinnen rumlaufen
darunter auch seine frau vor unserer
heirat habe ich hier die brüste ein
wenig vergrößert
diese nicht riesig und wir haben ein
bisschen fett abgesagt mal deine
problemzonen
nein im ernst ich denke es ist sehr
schön und ich hoffe dass sie nicht
findet sie brauche weitere operation ist
aber unser aussehen ist uns wichtig
frauen sind unsicher ja frauen ziemlich
notwendigerweise uns sicher aber sie
wollen so selbstbewusst wie möglich sein
männer und frauen können uns sicher sein
das ist eine frage der persönlichkeit
manche fügen sich jeden besser ganz
schönheitschirurgie ist 40 geworden und
muss schön bleiben
[Musik]
es ist nämlich einer der stars eine
reality tv serie namens the real
housewives of dallas
hier dreht sich alles um reiche menschen
um deren gramm rosenau tag wer sich vor
der kamera halten will der sollte nicht
gut sondern besser aussehen
[Applaus]
war schon mal eine von denen bei dr
ich hatte schon mal ihre nadel im
gesicht weil sie im fernsehen zu sehen
ist oder sie zu new york fashion week
eingeladen dafür braucht sie eine neue
garderobe ihr freund brad hat aus einer
der edelsten boutiquen in dallas wo er
arbeitet designerkleider mitgebracht
nun müssen harte entscheidungen
getroffen werden
du solltest alle mal anprobieren
ja ich würde sie alle anprobieren ich
ziehe dir den reißverschluss mal ganz
hoch ist das nicht toll
das sieht vor allem großartig an deinen
rüsten aus ich kenne mich aus mit
brüsten
das muss man sehen was da unten los
ich würde den reißverschluss bis in die
mit runterziehen
du musst hier bleiben mit so einem auto
das ich dich nicht lass mich das hier
mal anprobieren nur sonnenseiten hat es
allerdings nicht ein reality tv star zu
sein
sicher es gab auch schöne momente aber
nicht nur millionäre angelt man sich
indem man eine gewisse zeit auf den
knien unter ihrem schreibtisch
verbringen
[Musik]
okay zur besten sendezeit wurde
ausführlich spekuliert ob und wie carey
ihren mann seiner ersten frau
ausgespannt hat sie sind bekannt
geworden durch die reality serie mussten
sie für diese bekanntheit auch einen
preis zahlen
es gibt ein sprichwort so etwas wie
schlechte publicity gibt es nicht okay
vielleicht mussten wir einen preis zu
der preis war wohl dass die ganzen
dreharbeiten ziemlich stressig war alles
bei seinem passiert passiert doch aus
einem grund und man macht es das ein
grund es musste wohl so sein und es war
die sache wert
nein das ist nichts
wir sind auf twitter und werden dort ein
bisschen angepöbelt
aber wir haben dadurch viel mehr
patientinnen bekommen
darum haben wir dort auch mitgemacht
es war auch einfach eine neue erfahrung
der man wächst und in der man lernt und
dann muss es schnell gehen carey dollar
kurzfristig einen früheren flug gebucht
es galt zu verhindern dass sie in new
york eine wichtige party verpasst
nein
hey baby
stoiber hat die yogalehrerin noch einmal
bestellt also bei mir und sich selber
beweisen wollte dass er keineswegs
vergessen habe was ihn und dieses land
groß gemacht hat nämlich es noch einmal
zu versuchen noch besser werden zu
wollen es noch weiter zu bringen
hüftprobleme hin oder her
zwinker zwinker das schöne an amerika
ist doch dass es immer möglichkeiten
gibt weiter zu kommen und diese
möglichkeiten stehen und was machen die
zurückbleiben
die schicken wir vielleicht nach europa
eigentlich ein witz das ist bedauerlich
aber die welt dreht sich weiter
ich weiß auch keine antwort zum glück
muss ich das land nicht regieren
ich bin einfach glücklich dass die
menschen hier eine wahrheit und
vielleicht treffen die die zurückbleiben
einfach die falschen entscheidungen
vielleicht sei das nicht fair
es sei wahr und ich denke tatsächlich
wir leben in der besten aller möglichen
welten jedenfalls manche von uns
[Musik]